Dans les eaux troubles
de l'Atlantique Nord,
un animal s'adapte discrètement
à de profonds changements
de son environnement.
C'est l'un des plus grands prédateurs
du littoral européen.
Capable de chasser des proies
rapides et fugaces.
Le phoque gris.
On l'a souvent associé
à une adorable peluche blanche
ou à un clown de mer.
Et pourtant, son destin
est émaillé d'épreuves.
Depuis toujours, il doit faire face
à des superprédateurs.
Et depuis peu à des cannibales.
Aujourd'hui, on le surprend
à remonter les rivières
ou à la chasse aux marsouins.
Pour comprendre l'origine
de ces nouveaux comportements,
il faut musarder à ses côtés,
au cœur d'un océan, qui lui aussi,
s'est transformé.
Les rivages de l'Atlantique Nord
abritent les colonies de phoques gris.
Du Canada à la Suède en passant
par le Royaume-Uni,
ils affectionnent les eaux
tempétueuses et tempérées.
Depuis la fin des années 70
et l'arrêt de la chasse aux phoques,
la population augmentait
d'environ 10% par an.
Mais depuis quelques années,
elle plafonne.
Aujourd'hui, on commence tout juste
à comprendre l'origine de cette stagnation.
Grâce notamment au recensement annuel
et aux progrès des bagues
et des balises embarquées.
On connaissait la plupart
de ses activités côtières.
On découvre désormais
ses déambulations au large,
ses zones de chasse
et ses proies inattendues.
Septembre, un jeune mâle part
en quête d'une terre d'asile,
c'est-à-dire le plus souvent
d'une des nombreuses îles
qui constellent les eaux du Royaume-Uni,
où vivent 40% de la population mondiale
et 95% de la population européenne
de phoques gris.
Parmi elles, l'île de May,
à l'est de l'Écosse.
Ce jeune innocent tente sa chance
un peu au hasard.
Mais cette île est déjà occupée
par un phoque mâle de 270 kilos,
qui règne jalousement sur son territoire.
Le combat contre le poids lourd
est inégal.
Il va devoir partir ailleurs,
chercher une autre terre d'accueil.
On pensait que les phoques
étaient tous philopatriques,
autrement dit qu'ils revenaient sur
leur colonie natale pour se reproduire.
Mais les phoques porteurs
de balises ou de bagues,
ont montré qu'il y avait
de nombreuses exceptions.
Ils ont notamment prouvé
qu'un jeune mâle,
est capable de nager
plus de 1000 kilomètres
à la recherche d'une nouvelle colonie.
Le jeune mâle tente de s'approprier
les meilleures îles.
Des reposoirs isolés,
jamais totalement submergés.
D'autres phoques ont évidemment
eu la même idée.
Une explication musclée
avec le maître des lieux,
s'impose à nouveau.
La vie d'un jeune mâle
est assez peu enviable.
Pour trouver sa place en société, il doit
affronter tous les mâles dominants des îles.
S'il ne fait pas le poids,
il doit abdiquer.
Après avoir erré plusieurs semaines,
le jeune guerrier arrive enfin
à l'archipel des Orcades,
au nord de l'Écosse.
En vue, l'île de Westray.
Ces falaises semblent
totalement imprenables.
Depuis le début de son odyssée,
il aura longé toute la côte Est
du Royaume-Uni
et parcouru une distance équivalente
à un marathon par jour.
Pour arriver enfin sur l'îlot de Faray.
Dans une crique en apparence déserte.
En apparence seulement.
Un autre combat se profile.
Mais ici, son rival ne mesure
que deux mètres pour 150 kilos.
Victoire !
Durement acquise.
À son tour, il va défendre
son lopin de terre tout en jeûnant.
Son ambition : se reproduire.
Une semaine après son combat triomphal,
il est récompensé par l'arrivée de femelles
qu'il va prendre sous sa protection.
Plus petites, plus fines,
plus blanches et plus coquettes.
Le voici pacha
à la tête d'un harem de 7 irrésistibles
femelles grasses et morveuses.
Pendant six semaines,
il doit les surveiller jalousement.
Pour que d'autres mâles ne viennent pas
empiéter sur son territoire et son harem,
il s'escrime à les tenir à l'écart.
Sur de courtes distances, il peut ramper
aussi vite qu'un homme qui court.
De l'âge de dix ans jusqu'à leur mort
vers 25 ans,
les mâles phoques gris doivent se livrer
à une vingtaine de combats chaque automne.
Rarement mortels, ces affrontements laissent
aux combattants des cicatrices à vie.
Quant aux femelles,
elles ne sont pas arrivées seules.
Fécondées il y a onze mois,
elles viennent ici mettre bas.
Ce sont les plus grands animaux sauvages
qui se reproduisent à terre,
au Royaume-Uni.
Curieusement, il naît chaque année
dix femelles pour sept mâles.
Ses demi-frères et sœurs sont nés
à quelques jours d'intervalle.
Leur manteau blanc leur vaut
le surnom de Blanchons.
Les Blanchons ne suscitent aucun
instinct paternel chez le mâle,
qui ne participe jamais à leur éducation.
La femelle ne s'occupe des Blanchons que pendant
les 18 jours que dure l'allaitement.
Son secret ?
Un des laits les plus gras du monde.
Cinq litres de lait qui permettent
aux petits de gagner 2 kilos par jour.
Un véritable régime de sumo.
Les blanchons épuisent leurs mères
qui perdent jusqu'à 6 kilos par jour
et 40% de leur poids en moins
de trois semaines d'allaitement.
Toutes les nuits de novembre,
c'est le baby boom,
dans les maternités insulaires.
Sur l'île de Faray,
ce sont environ 12 000 phoques gris
qui s'entassent sur les plages à l'automne.
C'est la seconde plus grande
colonie du Royaume-Uni.
Depuis 2008, la population de cette île
ne croît que d'environ 4% par an,
soit près de trois fois moins
que dans les années 80.
Pourtant, les femelles sont toujours
aussi fécondes
et donnent naissance à une douzaine
de petits dans leur vie.
Les Blanchons seraient donc
victimes d'une surmortalité,
à partir du moment où ils quittent
le confort des maternités.
Après deux semaines passées dans
les souilles de boue à l'abri des tempêtes,
certaines femelles les invitent
à découvrir les joies des premiers bains.
Elles savent être persuasives.
Obnubilés par leurs mamelles,
les petits oublient qu'ils pénètrent
pour la première fois dans l'eau glacée.
Une méthode pédagogique très efficace.
Les mères incitent même
leurs rejetons à nager,
en les forçant à immerger
la tête sous l'eau.
Peu isoler du froid,
les blanchons prennent d'abord
des bains de courte durée.
Puis s'aventure seul et plus longtemps,
insouciant du danger,
d'un nouveau danger.
Un mâle adulte.
Aux mères le soin de le repousser.
En regroupant leurs petits en crèche,
les femelles coalisées parviennent
à juguler les ardeurs du mâle.
Malgré la différence de taille,
ce sont elles qui contrôlent le calendrier
de reproduction sur l'île.
Après précisément 18 jours
d'allaitement à jeun,
les femelles ne produisent
plus assez de lait.
Les petits vont devoir être sevrés.
Premier signe de leur émancipation,
la mue.
Les blanchons vont perdre progressivement
leur fourrure immaculée.
Pour réussir à s'en débarrasser,
tous les moyens sont bons.
Pendant ce temps,
certaines femelles affamées
regagnent l'océan pour se nourrir.
Leurs petits ne les reverront
probablement jamais.
Les voilà seuls, livrés à eux-mêmes,
au cœur de l'hiver.
Orphelin des tempêtes.
Un petit sur deux ne survit pas
à ce traitement de choc.
Pire, depuis quelques années,
ils doivent faire face à un ennemi intime.
Un mâle cannibale.
Il compte uniquement sur son poids
pour terrasser ses proies.
Sa mère, encore à proximité,
entend son cri de détresse.
Elle fait diversion.
Miraculeusement, le jeune phoque
s'en sort avec quelques blessures.
Ce mal cannibale reprend sa chasse.
Il guette le départ des mères pour
s'en prendre à des petits isolés.
Cette fois, rien ne peut le distraire.
Ce comportement a été observé
depuis le début des années 2000,
sur plusieurs îles britanniques.
Chaque phoque cannibale
tue environ 12 petits par an.
Curieusement, il ne prélève
qu'un lambeau de gras,
avant d'abandonner leur victime.
On pense que ce cannibalisme
est moins provoqué par la faim,
que par une frustration sexuelle.
En effet, leur stratagème ressemble
étrangement à celui mis au point
par des jeunes mâles.
Leur cible : les jeunes femelles
qui tentent de regagner l'île.
Sûrs de leur supériorité physique
et tels des cannibales,
ils vont tenter de les immobiliser
à faible profondeur.
Pincées et mordues à la nuque,
les femelles ne peuvent plus s'enfuir.
Le phoque est adepte de l'amour vache.
Les mâles pourraient
dévorer leur partenaire,
mais leur objectif est tout autre,
s'accoupler pour assurer leur descendance.
Ces jeunes phoques sont surnommés
les mâles périphériques.
On estime qu'ils ont 10 fois moins de chances
de se reproduire que les grands mâles.
Mais comme ils sont plus nombreux,
ils parviennent souvent à leurs fins.
Décembre marque la fin
de la saison des accouplements.
Toutes les femelles ont quitté l'île.
Seul reste en maraude
quelques mâles solitaires.
C'est le moment choisi par les derniers
orphelins pour prendre le large.
Affronter les tempêtes
et l'inconnu.
Depuis toujours, le calendrier de reproduction
du phoque gris semble paradoxal.
En effet, c'est en plein hiver
que les petits sont sevrés
et se retrouvent livrés à eux-mêmes
pour faire face à la violence des éléments.
Aux vagues.
Et depuis quelques années, aux mâles
qui ont pris goût à la viande de phoque.
Les petits doivent tromper la surveillance
du phoque cannibale pour gagner le large.
Ils improvisent.
Certains vont chercher des crevasses
pour s'échapper discrètement.
Victoire !
Ces failles offrent des sorties
dérobées vers le large.
Ce dernier phoque aura-t-il cette chance ?
Ce jeune phoque n'est pas parvenu
à semer le cannibale.
Que prépare ce mâle ?
Un baiser hypocrite
ou une farce de clown ?
Ni l'un ni l'autre.
Dans l'eau, le tueur ne peut utiliser
son poids pour saisir
et croquer les petits.
Ce jeune est passé.
Vers un océan déchaîné.
Son sort sera scellé par
les colères de l'hiver.
Ce candide doit survivre
au cœur des montagnes liquides,
où les poissons sont encore rares.
Pendant les premiers mois
de leur vie aquatique,
les phoques voient fondre leurs réserves
de graisse au contact de l'eau froide.
Comme cette jeune femelle.
Ses parents ne lui ont jamais
appris à chasser.
Que va-t-elle bien pouvoir manger ?
Une algue laminaire,
la salade de la mer du Nord.
Pas très nourrissant.
Mais jusqu'au printemps, elle peut
compter sur sa réserve de graisse,
pour lui permettre de survivre
en économisant ses stocks.
Comme l'eau froide brûle les graisses
plus rapidement que l'air,
les jeunes phoques effectuent de nombreux
séjours à terre pour préserver leurs réserves.
En moyenne, ils passent 4 jours en mer
pour un jour à terre.
Ils apprennent d'instinct
à se servir de leurs sens.
Leur vue sensible aux basses lumières,
tant sous l'eau que sur l'eau.
Elle leur permet de détecter
les mâles suspects qui rôdent.
Leur odorat qui, depuis leur naissance,
distingue l'odeur spécifique à chaque phoque.
Enfin, un sens du toucher à distance
grâce à leurs vibrisses,
c'est-à-dire leurs moustaches.
Elles sont dix fois plus sensibles
que celles des chats.
Même dans l'obscurité, elle capte les ondes
créées par les corps en mouvement.
Ces ondes ne sont pas celles produites
par un mâle en maraude.
Cette barrique de graisse,
profite des joies d'une thalassothérapie
à l'eau froide.
Tout en dormant,
ce mal régule sa température
en maintenant son corps immergé
dans l'eau glacée.
Le jeune phoque peut donc aisément
tromper sa vigilance.
Et en apparence, la voie est libre.
Plus d'ondes suspectes.
C'est le moment idéal
pour prendre le large.
Pourtant, son ouïe détecte
d'étranges sifflements,
de plus en plus présents.
Venant de toutes les directions.
Et mélangée à des cliquetis.
La baleine tueuse.
Venue en famille chasser le phoque.
Les plus expérimentés donnent
loisir aux plus jeunes,
de s'entraîner à assommer le phoque.
Avant de partager le repas en famille.
Depuis la nuit des temps, les baleines
tueuses, également appelées orques,
chassent le phoque.
Celles de l'Atlantique Nord
consomment aussi du poisson.
Mais comme cette ressource tend à s'amenuiser,
elles se rabattent sur les phoques.
On les observe de plus en plus souvent
près des côtes.
Aussi, tous les phoques,
jeunes ou adultes,
doivent apprendre à vivre
avec leurs sombres menaces.
Celui qui a échappé à une attaque d'orque
sait les repérer à distance.
Même en dormant.
En gonflant ses poumons,
le phoque fait la bouteille.
Il ne se repose que d'un oeil
pendant ses odyssées.
Ses vibrisses détectent toute vibration
inhabituelle en surface
et de l'autre côté du miroir.
Son ouïe, plus sensible
dans l'eau que dans l'air,
identifie de loin les signatures vocales
de son ennemi mortel.
La simple vue de l'aileron dorsal,
terrorise tous les phoques.
Et pour cause.
Sous ce couteau noir d'1m80
pour le mâle adulte,
se cache un prédateur de neuf tonnes.
Pire, les orques chassent en meute
et sont capables
de pointes de vitesse à 70 km/h.
Les phoques ne peuvent rivaliser.
Seul salut possible :
rassemblement sur un abri de fortune.
Pour attraper les phoques,
les orques ne peuvent s'échouer sur
ces rochers coiffés de coquillages.
Ils déchiquetteraient leur épiderme.
Elles tentent alors
de brouiller les pistes.
Les femelles et les jeunes
restent sous la surface
et changent rapidement de position,
pendant que le mâle se montre ostensiblement
pour effrayer les phoques.
En vain.
Les phoques ne bougent pas.
Aussi, les orques préfèrent
passer leur chemin,
pour tenter de surprendre ailleurs
des jeunes phoques imprudents.
Les orcs apparaissent exclusivement
à la fin du printemps
et en été au nord du Royaume-Uni.
Pour une bonne raison.
Ce calendrier correspond au moment
où les phoques sont les plus gras.
À la fin du printemps, tous les phoques
ont quitté la maternité de Faray.
Et pour cause, le retour du soleil
déclenche dans la mer du Nord,
une explosion de vie,
donc de proies disponibles
pour les phoques.
La lumière stimule l'explosion
de phytoplancton,
des algues microscopiques qui donnent
aux eaux de surface leur teinte émeraude,
des algues qui vont à leur tour nourrir
des petits poissons et crustacés,
eux-mêmes mangés par des prédateurs.
Dans les trois ans qui suivent
le départ de leur île natale,
les jeunes phoques partent en quête
de ses proies au hasard des courants.
Sans port d'attache, ils se dispersent.
Ainsi, en quittant Faray,
un phoque a d'abord visité
la pointe nord de l'Écosse,
en passant dans le détroit
du Pentland Firth
et ses remarquables aiguilles
de grès rouge.
Des étranges formations géologiques
rongées par la mer et le vent.
Puis il a fait demi-tour.
Et mis le cap au sud,
en s'aventurant le long
de la côte ouest de l'Écosse.
Comme il n'a jamais reçu
de leçons de chasse de ses parents,
il navigue à l'instinct,
en observant ses semblables
ou d'autres animaux marins.
Promesse de festin.
Parmi ces meilleurs indicateurs,
les fous de Bassan.
Ces patrouilles de kamikazes repèrent
leurs victimes sous la surface.
Avant de fondre sur elle en piqué,
jusqu'à l'incroyable vitesse de 110 km/h.
Avec les goélands
et autres oiseaux marins,
le phoque s'invite à la table des fous
et finit les restes du banquet.
Son instinct ne l'a pas trompé.
Au fil des rencontres,
ce phoque aura nagé
plus de 1000 km en trois ans,
pour finalement atteindre
le Pays de Galles
et l'île de Ramsey.
Elle est séparée de la terre
par un isthme étroit,
en forme d'entonnoir où s'engouffrent
des violents courants,
créés par les flux de marée.
Il draine des eaux froides et des nutriments
venus des profondeurs.
24 h sur 24, ils assurent
une livraison de nourriture,
pour des centaines de prédateurs marins
réunis dans la passe.
Parmi eux, un petit cétacé furtif,
le Marsouin.
Ce bolide de 60 kilos déjoue
la force du courant de Ramsey,
pour attraper plus de cinq kilos
de poisson par jour.
Depuis quelques années, on a remarqué
que quelques mâles phoque gris,
s'intéressaient de près
à ces cétacés côtiers.
Bien qu'à l'aise dans le courant,
le phoque gris ne peut rivaliser
de vitesse avec les marsouins.
Toute course poursuite
est vouée à l'échec.
Alors il utilise une autre stratégie.
Le phoque imite celle des grands félins
pour surprendre ses proies.
La chasse en embuscade.
Problème : la visibilité
ne dépasse pas quelques mètres
et l'empêche de chasser à vue.
Heureusement, ces vibrisses sont plus sensibles
aux ondes créées par des corps en mouvement,
dans l'eau que dans l'air.
Elles agissent comme
un sondeur multifaisceaux
et donnent des informations sur la position,
le sens de déplacement
et la vitesse des marsouins.
Ainsi au cœur de la passe
et son trafic incessant de marsouins,
le phoque attend le passage de sa proie,
pour tenter de la surprendre
et l'intercepter.
En vain.
Il manque encore de pratique.
Pourtant, ici et dans d'autres goulets
de l'océan Atlantique,
des phoques mâles dévorent désormais
plus d'une dizaine de marsouins par an.
On n'a jamais encore observé
d'attaque de marsouins par des femelles.
On pense qu'elles se concentrent
sur des proies plus petites.
Ainsi, en quête de nourriture,
une femelle a quitté l'île de Faray
pour rejoindre les rivages
des îles Shetland.
Curieusement, les apnées des femelles
sont en moyenne plus longues,
mais moins profondes
que celles des mâles.
6 contre 5 minutes et 48 contre 57 m.
Conséquence : les femelles chassent
essentiellement à proximité des côtes
pour chercher leur pitance.
Ainsi, au sud-ouest des îles Shetland,
la femelle affectionne
les plages de sable blanc,
notamment celles de l'île de Saint-Ninian.
Au cœur de ces baies abritées
se cachent des poissons invisibles.
Les rois du camouflage,
qui ne résistent pas aux peignes
de ses vibrisses.
Des limandes.
Gare aux goélands qui viendraient
jouer les profiteurs.
Les femelles commencent à enfanter
dès l'âge de quatre ans
et doivent donc commencer très jeune
à se constituer des réserves de graisse.
À la recherche de nouveaux
territoires de chasse,
ces femelles et tous les phoques gris,
découvrent désormais un nouveau monde.
Un océan étrange peuplé de bouées colorées
comme des ballons de baudruche
et de monstres en acier,
qui ronronnent au cœur de gradins
en béton garnis de goélands.
Bref, un océan transformé,
dans lequel doivent désormais évoluer
tous les prédateurs de l'Atlantique.
Même les orques.
À la découverte de ce monde étrange,
deux phoques ont quitté ensemble Faray
et longé la côte Est de l'Écosse
jusqu'en Angleterre.
Ils s'aperçoivent que d'autres
phoques gris ne s'émeuvent pas
de la présence des géants d'acier
qui peuplent ces eaux troubles.
En remontant la rivière Tees,
les phoques rencontrent
un monde de métal et de béton,
qui fume et bourdonne au rythme
des marées et des voitures.
Ils ne sont pas les seuls
à nager à contre courant.
À la marée montante, les saumons
atlantiques remontent le flux,
dans l'espoir de trouver
quelques frayères,
celles où ils sont nés.
Avec leur odorat très développé,
ils sont aimantés
par des effluves diffuses.
L'odeur propre à la rivière Tees.
Les phoques espèrent évidemment
pouvoir se repaître de ces poissons.
Mais ils restent insaisissables,
en pleine eau.
Par chance, l'homme et son goût immodéré
pour le béton et le métal,
vont leur donner un petit coup de pouce.
En amont des bouées,
les phoques ont découvert
un mur totalement infranchissable.
Un barrage.
Le courant de la marée montante,
draine d'autres phoques qui convergent
vers l'entonnoir en béton.
Tous attendent l'ouverture des vannes.
L'eau douce déversée,
fera monter en surface les saumons
pressés de pondre en amont,
pour le bonheur des phoques.
Chaque jour d'été,
les phoques dévorent
moins de 7% des saumons,
qui tentent de franchir le barrage.
En montant, la mère finit par compenser
le courant de la rivière
et engloutit les vannes.
Les saumons peuvent alors aisément
rejoindre leur frayères,
en amont du barrage.
Quant aux phoques
et notamment cette femelle,
ils peuvent enfin digérer leur repas
et se délasser dans un bain moussant.
Une femelle phoque gris
consomme en moyenne
2,5 kg de poisson par jour
contre trois pour un mâle.
Et plus le poisson est gras,
moins il en faut.
Or, les saumons sont gras
et nourrissants à souhait,
mais pas toujours aussi facile à capturer.
Comme va le découvrir une femelle
qui s'est aventurée en Écosse.
Elle a découvert des rangées
d'étranges structures cylindriques,
les fermes à saumon.
Dix cages de 40 mètres de diamètre.
Elle enferme plus d'un million de saumons.
Des fruits défendus qui restent
inaccessibles aux phoques.
Au total, il y a désormais près
de 350 fermes à saumon au Royaume-Uni,
essentiellement en Écosse
et dans ses îles.
Ces cages créent des écosystèmes miniatures
à plusieurs centaines de mètres à la ronde.
Les farines, les excréments
et les parasites,
nourrissent de nombreux poissons
qui vivent à l'extérieur des cages.
Comme ces lieux, les phoques
peuvent parfaitement s'en contenter.
Mais les exploitants des fermes,
ne font pas de différence entre un phoque
qui chasse les lieux autour des cages
et un voleur de saumons.
Les poissons d'élevage restent
la propriété de l'homme,
qui se donne tous les moyens
pour les protéger.
Les phoques paient le prix fort
pour leur curiosité.
Au Royaume-Uni, la loi autorise
l'abattage des phoques,
soupçonnés de chaparder
des poissons d'élevage.
Rien ne les prépare
à cette justice expéditive.
En mer Baltique,
sur le littoral de la Suède,
les pêcheurs entrent également
en conflit avec les phoques.
Dans les années 2000,
ils ont inventé des pièges,
qui sont formés d'un filet
qui barre la route aux poissons côtiers,
puis d'un entonnoir en filet
qui les font converger vers une nasse.
Dans leur sillage,
ils entraînent les phoques.
Quelques caméras de surveillance
les surprennent
en flagrant délit de vol de saumons,
de morue et de harengs.
En remontant leur piège,
les pêcheurs ne collectent souvent
que les miettes des repas des phoques.
Les stocks de poissons de la Baltique
sont surexploités et s'amenuisent.
Inévitablement, les phoques gris,
deviennent les coupables
tout trouvés de cette surpêche.
Leurs populations sont sévèrement impactées
par des morts accidentelles dans les filets
et des abattages autorisés.
Depuis le début du XXᵉ siècle,
la moitié des effectifs
de la mer Baltique a disparu.
Aujourd'hui, à l'image de celle des autres
phoques gris de l'Atlantique Nord,
la population de Faray
fluctue essentiellement,
au rythme des ressources
alimentaires disponibles.
Des nouveaux prédateurs
et des mortalités accidentelles.
Autant de facteurs qui expliquent
la stagnation de leur population.
Il y a aujourd'hui moins de phoques gris
que d'éléphants d'Afrique,
mais comme ils sont concentrés
sur les rivages de l'Atlantique Nord,
ils donnent l'impression de prospérer.
Au contact des engins de pêche,
de nombreux phoques disparaissent en mer,
sans laisser de traces.
Certains survivent.
Comme cette femelle réchappée
miraculeusement des mailles d'un filet.
Sur l'origine des prédations,
sur les proies inhabituelles,
on ne peut que spéculer.
Mais les soupçons portent encore
sur l'industrie de la pêche.
En prélevant les ressources disponibles,
elles forcent les phoques à trouver
d'autres sources de protéines.
Pour survivre dans cet océan transformé,
les futures générations de phoques
devront à leur tour,
adapter leurs déplacements
et comportements.
Ainsi, les phoques aujourd'hui martyrisés
dans le nord du Royaume-Uni,
s'installent plus au sud,
notamment à Blakeney Point.
Sur ces rivages, nul orque
et nul piège ou fermes à saumons.
Un nouvel Eldorado où les phoques
sont intégralement protégés,
alors qu'ils y ont été décimés
dès le XIXᵉ siècle.
Ici naissait 25 petits en 2001.
Aujourd'hui, c'est plus de 2000 blanchons
qui viennent au monde chaque année
pour créer la plus grande colonie
de reproduction de l'Angleterre.
Preuve qu'un peu de poisson
et de protection,
suffisent au phoque gris pour prospérer.
Un message assez simple
pour qui veut bien l'entendre.